we are watching the real time panic and
collapse of aspects of the Republican
party in particular much of the trumpian
wing of the Republican Party Donald
Trump's former press secretary Kaylee
mcinanny in reaction to the disastrous
midterm results four Republicans
particularly Mega Republicans and some
of the critical Trump endorsed people on
Fox news said
Trump should not announce that he is
running for president on Tuesday Kaylee
mcineny is telling Trump
cancel the announcement at least
postpone it because of what happened on
Tuesday and the fact that Republicans
now need to figure out how do you win in
Georgia Mac and Annie also even saying
Trump shouldn't even campaign for
Herschel Walker it should be Ron
DeSantis a very different Kaylee mcinany
than the one that prayed at the altar of
trump when of course she was paid for
him as it makes sense to do listen to
this and that could go straight through
the state of Georgia does that include
Trump I think he needs to put it on
pause absolutely look he'll make that
decision he'll make his own decision but
does he go I'm advising any Contender
DeSantis Trump whomever no one announces
2024 until we get through December 6th
do you see the former president I need
for him to go to Georgia I I think we've
got to make strategic calculations
um Governor DeSantis I think he should
be welcome to the state given what
happened last night you gotta look at
the realities on the ground and Herschel
Walker we've got to win the Senate
that's it guys gotta win the Senate all
right we'll move on uh now understand
yes
to some degree announcing that you're
running for president when it's not even
clear who won the Senate is a bad look
for anyone that is absolutely true and
that's not specific to Trump but there's
a bigger story here which is it appears
as though Trump would not even be useful
to Herschel Walker in Georgia it's not
clear to me in fact let me put it a
different way it is clear to me that if
Trump does a rally for Herschel Walker I
don't think it helps Herschel Walker at
all at this point in time in Georgia and
we're going to be doing everything we
can to activate to get that get that
seat uh held by Raphael Warnock but will
Walker tell Trump to stay away
that would be interesting to see will
Ron desantisco because remember Ron
DeSantis won by 19 he over performed the
polls almost 2x winning by 19 instead of
I think it was 11 which was the polls
projection
and he's in the neighboring state of
Florida he's way more popular at this
point the betting markets ha in fact
let's let's check what the betting where
the betting markets are right now uh as
of yesterday they looked quite good for
um for Ron DeSantis uh Republican
nominee
uh
as of this point in time
uh it's actually tightened up a little
bit it's now tightened up to santis and
Trump basically leaving everybody else
behind the betting markets now feel that
this is basically DeSantis versus Trump
so it's not clear that Trump would help
Trump may actually hurt this is a race
that Republicans need and Kaylee
mcinanny is saying Trump shouldn't even
announce on Tuesday they're although the
event on Tuesday has not been canceled
there are Rumblings that it is not just
Kaylee mcineny telling Trump to hold off
on announcing that he is running and if
Trump indeed decides not to go forward
with that on Tuesday I think it will be
very quietly announced and then
rescheduled for some future point I also
have viewers writing to me saying David
I'm not convinced Trump's really going
to run Trump announced the November 15
thing before seeing the results of the
election now that he has seen them he
might not run now if Trump were normal
that might be plausible as the epitome
of the ultimate narcissist I don't know
that the results will actually dissuade
Trump we're going to wait and see good
habits have to be sustainable in order
to become habits it has to be something
you'll actually do and when it comes to
nutrition some people have hours to plan
out every meal their exact vitamin
intake I'm not doing any of that I don't
have the time here's what's sustainable
for me I start my day with just a single
scoop of ag-1 from athletic greens it
gives me the entire day's worth of the
75 high quality vitamins minerals and
probiotics I want from whole food
sources it's just simple it's just one
scoop of ag1 I get all the nutrients I
want I don't have to do any math use my
protractor my TI-83 or take a bunch of
different capsules and pills it's not
some kind of wacky supplement making a
bunch of crazy claims you know I would
not promote something like that ag1 is
just a simple product it does what it
says it does it gives you the daily
nutrients and vitamins you likely want
vitamin A C E magnesium zinc potassium
in one simple scoop you keep your body
nourished you'll also get a free year
supply of vitamin D which I take in the
winter plus five free travel packs at
athleticgreens.com Pacman the link is
down below